Çeviri: Gözde Caymazer
Gözden geçirme: Erman Turkmen
Capital Turkish Connections
Dünyanın herhangi bir yerinde
iki Türk bir araya gelince
konu her zaman malum soruya geliyor:
"Ne olacak bu memleketin hali?"
Şimdi aranızda bu soruyu soranlar var mı?
Varsa ellerini görebilir miyim?
Neyse en azından
iyi bir tespitle başladık,
bundan sonra devam edebiliriz rahatlıkla.
Her şey bir kahve sohbetiyle başladı.
Çalıştığımız iş yerinin kafeteryasında
-ben bir ekonomist, arkadaşım bir avukat-
bir peçete kağıdının üzerine
acaba uluslararası alanda
biriktirdiğimiz bilgi deneyimlerini
nasıl ülkemize aktarırız
diye yazmaya başladık.
Üç tane nokta koyduk oraya.
Birincisi; eğer böyle bir şey
yapacaksak büyük bir hedefimiz olmalı.
Bu hedef nasıl tanımlanmalı diye
düşünürken şunları yazdık.
Ülkemizi dünyadaki en iyi
on ülke arasına nasıl getirebiliriz?
Çok büyük bir hedef.
Uygulanabilir mi uygulanamaz mı
üzerine kafa yormaya başladık.
Düşündük, galiba olur dedik.
O zaman bir şekilde
yola koyulmamız lazım.
Böyle büyük bir hedef olacaksa
geniş bir insan ağına ihtiyacımız var.
Bunları beraber getirmemiz lazım
ve belli prensipler çerçevesinde de
bu kişilerin çalışmasına
imkan sağlamamız gerekli.
Normal koşullarda herhalde
bu tarz sohbeti ben o günden önce
yüzlerce kez yapmışımdır.
Her yapılan bu sohbet
sonrasında da kahvemizi içip,
sohbetimizi yapıp ayrılmışızdır.
Nedense o gün ayrılmamaya
karar verdik ve yola koyulduk.
Neden olduğunu bilmiyorum
açıkçası, demek ki denk geldi.
Şimdi ilk olarak size dünyanın
ilk on ülkesi arasına
girmek tanımını biraz
verilerle göstereyim.
Burada gördüğünüz çemberin
etrafında çeşitli göstergeler bulunuyor.
Çemberin ne kadar
dışındaysanız o kadar kötü.
Çemberin dışından merkeze
doğru giden o çizgiler,
bu göstergelerde ülkelerin
sıralamalarını gösteriyor.
Çemberin merkezine ne kadar gidiyorsanız
sıralamada da yeriniz o kadar iyi oluyor.
Yeşil ile gösterdiğimiz alan,
dünyadaki bu alanlarda
ilk on ülkenin bulunduğu
sınırları gösteriyor.
Mavi ile gösterdiğimiz yerler ise
Türkiyemizi temsil ediyor.
Mesela milli gelir
göstergesine baktığımızda
Türkiye dünyanın en büyük
20 ekonomisi arasında.
İnanılmaz bir nüfusu var
ve çok büyük potansiyel var.
Ancak bu gelirin sahaya
yayılmadığını görüyoruz.
Kişi başı milli gelir denilen
veriye baktığımızda da
Türkiye'nin önünde elli tane daha
fazla ülkenin olduğu ortaya çıkıyor.
Aynı şekilde mutluluk,
insani gelişmişlik, cinsiyet eşitliği,
rekabetçilik alanlarında da
önümüzde 70’ten fazla ülke var.
Yani mesafe çok uzun
fakat yapılamaz değil.
Kahve sonrasında hemen ofislere gittik,
telefonlara sarıldık.
Emaillerle ilk olarak
arkadaşlarımıza ulaştık.
Kendi networkümüzden
insanlara bu soruyu sorduk.
Türkiye'yi önümüzdeki yirmi yıl
içerisinde dünyanın ilk on ekonomisi,
ilk on ülkesi arasına
sokabilir miyiz diye.
Bu fikirlerimizi açtık, onlar da
geri bildirimlerde bulundular ve
diğer arkadaşlarımızı dahil etmek
için onlar da işe sarıldılar.
Tabi bu gördüğünüz değişkenler
birçok alana yayılıyor.
Benim işim iktisatçılık.
Bundan dolayı milli gelir ve
kişi başı milli gelir üzerine
bazı politikalar önerebilirim.
Ancak çok daha geniş bir kitleye
ulaşmamız gerekliydi.
Kendi networkümüzde de
bu tarz insanları bulamadık.
Bir avukat ve bir ekonomist
bir araya geliyorlar,
en fazla ekonomistlere
ve avukatlara ulaşıyorlar.
Bunun üzerine Google ve Linkedin
üzerinden bir dolu Türk uzmanı bulduk.
Öyle bir şey karşımıza çıktı ki
dünyanın her yerine yayılmış,
Türkiye'de ve dünyada takip edilen,
kendi alanında iyi olan insanlar varmış.
Bunlara kendi derdimizi anlattıktan sonra
birer video konferans için randevu aldık.
Uzun uzun konuştuk, onları da ikna ettik,
grubumuza dahil oldular.
Biz o kahve sırasında olur mu
olmaz mı derken iki kişilik ekip,
birdenbire bir hafta
içerisinde 10 kişiye,
ondan çok daha kısa bir zaman sonra da
dünyanın önemli başkentlerinde ve
çekim merkezi güçlü olan şehirlerinde
geniş bir Türk uzman ağına ulaşmış olduk.
Tabi bu olay Washington DC’de başladı
ama şu anda özellikle birazdan
bahsedeceğim projede çalışan
arkadaşların çoğunluğu Türkiye
Cumhuriyeti sınırları içerisinde yaşıyor.
Şimdi amacımız var.
Bu ilk onun nasıl olduğunu tanımladık.
Çok güzel de bir network oluşturduk,
yüzlerce uzman var
fakat bunun ikisini nasıl
bir araya getireceğiz?
Bunun için yani bu işin çerçevesi nedir?
Üç tane temel prensip üzerinden
hareket etmeye karar verdik.
Bunlardan birincisi fikirlerimizi öne
sürerken mutlaka veriye dayalı olması.
İkincisi uzun vadeye odaklanması.
Üçüncüsü ise pozitif bir yaklaşımla
ele alınması.
Veriye dayalı olmak yaşadığımız
dünyayı iyi anlamamıza neden oluyor.
Ne kadar verilere bakarsanız
kendi dünyanızı iyi anlarsınız,
başkalarını iyi anlarsınız, başkalarının
nereye gideceğini çok iyi analiz edersiniz
ve bu çerçevede daha iyi
sonuçlara yol açıyor.
İkincisi ise uzun vadeye dedik.
Uzun vadeye odaklanmak aslında
günlük aciliyetiyle yaşadığımız
bu dünyada birçok uzun vadeli
hedeflerden arada bir sapıyoruz.
Mesela Türkiye yirmi yıl sonra
eğitimde nerede olacak,
inovasyonda nerede olacak?
Bu tarz hedefleri her zaman
aklımızın arkasında tutmak lazım.
Bizi odaklanmaya itiyor.
Üçüncüsü ise pozitif ve
yapıcı olmak dedik.
Bu ise bütünleştirici bir unsur.
İnsanları bir araya getiriyor
ama aynı zamanda sorunlar yerine
çözümler üzerinde odaklanmamız
konusunda bize yardımcı oluyor.
Şimdi üç tane bu
noktamızı birleştiriyoruz.
İnsanlarımız var, hedefimiz var,
prensiplerimiz var.
Tam olarak ne yapalım derken
şans eseri çalıştığım kurumda
o an Şili üzerine yapılan
bir sunumu izledim.
Bundan dört yıl önce Şili'li bir iş adamı
oranın önde gelen ekonomistlerinden
biri ile oturuyor
“ne olacak bu memleketin hali?” diyor.
2 milyon dolar finansmanla
on iki kişilik bir uzman ekibi
bir araya getiriyorlar ve bu uzman ekip,
on sekiz ay çalıştıktan sonra
bir reform paketi ile ortaya çıkıyor.
İşin enteresan tarafı bu reform
paketlerini benim çalıştığım kurumda
anlatırken ilk kıyasladıkları ülke
Türkiye.
Birçok alanda Türkleri kendilerine
örnek alıyorlar ve
bizim uyguladığımız bazı politikaların
uygulanması için bir ajanda oluşturuyorlar
Şu andaki hükümet, Şili’de yapılan
bu reform paketinin mesela
eğitim ve iş gücü piyasalarıyla ilgili
olan alanlarını uygulamaya geçmiş durumda.
Yakın zamanda da sonuçlarını alacaklar.
Ben de kendi işimde aslında Şili’yi örnek
aldığım bir ülke olarak her zaman gördüm.
Kişibaşı milli gelir de bizden
birazcık daha iyi.
Bürokrasisi ve teknokrasisi açısından
da bize çok benziyor.
Kaliteli insan gücüne sahipler.
Şimdi bu Şili’deki örnek aslında bize
çok güzel bir ilham kaynağı oldu.
Fakat bu arkadaşların yaptığı,
bizim yapmak istediğimizin
çok daha kısıtlı bir versiyonu.
On iki kişiyle, çoğunluğu ekonomist olan
bir grupla bir ajanda yapıyorlar,
sadece ekonomi odaklı ve biraz farklı
alanlara da yayılıyorlar.
Bizim ise yapmak istediğimiz şey
çok daha geniş bir kadroda,
çok daha farklı fikirleri
bir araya getirmek.
Şimdi isterseniz bu genişlikle ilgili
birkaç tane konuya değinelim.
Birkaç tane veri şimdi göstereceğim.
İşim gereği dünyanın birçok yerinde
politika yapıcılarıyla, özel sektörle,
sivil toplum kuruluşlarıyla ve sokaktaki
insanlarla konuşmam oluyor.
Dünyanın neresine gidersem gideyim
o insanlara sorduğumda
bu kişiler kendi ülkelerinin dünyanın
merkezinde olduğunu idda ediyorlar.
Gerçekten de böyle.
Makedonya’da yaptığım bir çalışmada
birçok insanla görüştüm ve
dediler ki Makedonya dünyanın merkezinde.
Çünkü Selanik limanına gelen herhangi
bir mal mutlaka Makedonya üzerinden
Doğu Avrupa’ya geçmek zorunda.
Onun için biz bu bölgenin merkezindeyiz.
Şimdi size bir soru soracağım ve
burada sizden samimi bir cevap bekliyorum.
Sizce Türkiye ekonomik olarak
dünyanın merkezinde mi?
Merkezinde diye düşünenler
lütfen elini kaldırsın.
Merkezinde olmadığını düşünenler
elini kaldırsın.
Bir iyi haber, bir kötü haber
size vereceğim.
Kötü haber:
evet, ülkemiz dünyanın merkezinde değil.
Tamam da biz bunu nasıl ölçüyoruz?
Dünya Bankası’nın veri tabanında
uzaklık denilen bir endeks var.
Bu uzaklık, bir ülkeyi dünyanın
merkezine koyuyor ve dünyadaki diğer
ticaret merkezleriyle olan arasındaki
mesafeden bir metrik oluşturuyor.
Bu metriğe göre Türkiye,
dünyada otuz beşinci sırada.
Dünyanın merkezi ise Türkiye'nin
biraz daha batısında ve kuzeyinde.
Bu endekste birinci sırada olan
iki ülke Danimarka ve Norveç.
Ama şimdi de size iyi haberi söyleyeyim.
Biraz önce dedik ki Türkiye dünyadaki
en iyi ilk on arasına gelecek.
Onlara kıyasla Türkiye'nin çok daha
önemli bir coğrafi pozisyonu var.
6.306 kilometre uzaklıkla,
dünyadaki ilk onun bulunduğu pozisyona
ortalamaya göre Türkiye’nin
coğrafi bir avantajı var.
Şimdi bir ekonomist olarak bu işe
baktığımızda hemen bu coğrafi avantajı
doğru alanlarda kullanıyor muyuz
diye birkaç tane veriye bakıyoruz.
Bunlardan biri dış ticaret verisi.
Eğer coğrafi olarak dünyanın
merkezindeyseniz ya da
diğer ülkelere göre daha iyi iseniz
demek ki sizin dünyanın geri kalanı ile
daha iyi dış ticaret
imkanlarınızın olması lazım.
Çünkü taşıma maliyetleri düşük.
Gemiler Türkiye’den Avrupa’ya
rahatlıkla gidiyor
ya da Orta Doğu’ya
rahatlıkla gidiyorlar.
Ama verilere baktığımızda Türkiye,
bu ilk on ekonominin yarısı kadar
dış ticaret gösterebiliyor.
Bu çok enteresan.
Tabi ilk eleştiri bu tarzda verilere
şöyle geliyor, dünya değişti
artık teknoloji ön plana geldi.
Bir yerden bir gemi buğdayı alıyorsunuz
dünyanın öbür tarafına gönderiyorsunuz.
Bunun taşıma maliyeti,
o buğdaydan elde edeceğiniz
gelirin çok küçük bir fraksiyonu.
Ama aynı gemiye
bilgisayarları koyduğunuz da
bunun taşıma maliyeti çok daha düşük.
O zaman dış ticarete konu olan
teknoloji malları,
belki dünya ticaretinde
daha fazla yer almaya başladı.
Onun için bir bakalım gerçekten de
Türkiye bu konuda ne durumda.
Burada internet kullanıcılarını
görüyorsunuz.
Türkiye’nin inanılmaz bir potansiyeli var.
Çünkü şu anda her iki kişiden biri
sadece internet kullanıyor.
Eğer biz bu insanlarla rekabet edeceksek,
%86’lardan daha fazla oranlara gelmemiz
lazım bu yeni akım olan
teknolojiden faydalanmamız için.
Ancak biz bu konuda neler yapıyoruz?
Türkiye’deki ar-ge harcamaları, dünyadaki
bu ilk on ekonomi dediğimiz
harcamaların üçte birini teşkil ediyor.
Eğer biz onlarla rekabet edeceksek
teknolojik altyapımızın iyi olması lazım.
Bu da araştırma ve geliştirme ile olur.
Bizim %0.8’lerden bu rakamları
3’lere çıkarmamız lazım ya da
3.5 - 4’lere çıkarmamız lazım.
Sonuçta, onlar da dünyada
rekabet etmek istiyorlar ve
bu rakamları daha da arttırmak istiyorlar.
Şimdi bu mevcut kaynaklarımızı
iyi kullanmadığımız görünüyor.
Fakat gerçekten tek kullanmadığımız
kaynağımız bunlar mı?
Türkiye nüfüsunun yarısı olan
kadınlarımızı iş gücüne dahil etmiyoruz.
OECD ülkeleri arasında verilere
bakıldığında Türkiye’de kadınların
işgücüne katılımı %30’ların altında.
OECD ortalaması bunun
iki katından daha fazla.
İnanılmaz bir potansiyel var,
bunu kullanmıyoruz.
Kullandığımız potansiyelleri de
sekiz kat daha olasılıkla
trafik kazalarında kaybediyoruz.
Trajikomik bir durum.
Biz bu verileri mümkün olduğu kadar
geniş bir alana yayabiliriz
ama bu hikaye değişmeyecek açıkçası.
Katedilecek büyük bir mesafemiz var.
Bu, bir potansiyelimiz
olduğunu gösteriyor.
Fakat nasıl yapabileceğimiz ile ilgili
bir yol haritasına ihtiyacımız var.
Şimdi biz bu grubu oluştururken
birkaç şeye çok dikkat ettik.
Özellikle grup büyürken
profesyonellerden oluşmasını istedik.
Çünkü veriye dayalı kendi uzmanlık
alanlarında bize hikayelerini,
bize önerilerini vermelerini istedik.
Bu süre içerisinde çok enteresan bir
profilde insan yapısına ulaştık.
Üniversitelerde akademisyenler,
dekanlar, rektörler,
milyar dolarlık şirketlerin CEO’ları,
bankaların başındaki insanlar,
uluslararası finans kuruluşlarında
yöneticiler, uzmanlar ya da
kariyerinin başındaki profesyonel
insanları bu gruba dahil ettik.
Ama bu süreç içerisinde dedik ki,
her gelen bir kadınla beraber bir
erkeğin burada olması lazım.
Her gelen bir erkekle beraber bir
kadının burada olması lazım.
Onun için bu yüz kişiyi aşkın grup
dediğimiz insanın ellisi kadın,
ellisi erkek civarında gibi
bir sonuca ulaştık.
Aynı zamanda farklı bir şey
daha yapalım dedik,
genç insanlara ulaşalım.
Farklı fikirden ve farklı görüşlerden
insanları da bu grubun içine dahil edelim.
Sonuçta böyle kapsamlı bir proje
yapacaksanız mümkün olduğu kadar
farklı insanları bu projenin
içine dahil etmeniz gerekiyor.
Bu grup çok uzun bir süre çalıştı.
Yaklaşık 2 yıl kadar.
Bir dolu öneriyle geldiler.
Telekonferanslar yapıldı.
Biliyorsunuz dünyanın her yanına
yayılmış insanlar bunlar.
Video konferanslar, çok ciddi şekillerde
insanlar cumartesilerinden, pazarlarından
hafta içi işlerinden fedakarlık
yaparak bu konferanslara katıldılar.
Arada bir de yüz yüze görüştüler.
Washington’da, Londra’da, İstanbul’da,
Ankara’da, Adana’da bile buluşuldu.
İki yıllık bu çalışmanın sonucunda
yüzlerce öneri arasından daha iyi
bir Türkiye için 92 öneri ortaya çıktı.
Türkiye Cumhuriyeti’nin
92. yıldönümünde 92 öneri.
Şimdi isterseniz bu önerilerin
birazcık detaylarına girelim.
Bu iki yıllık süre içerisinde en fazla
konuşulan şeylerden biri
kurumsal altyapının iyileştirilmesi
ile ilgili önerilerdi.
Mesela kamu projelerinde etki
analizlerinin kullanılması,
kamu projelerinin şeffaflık çerçevesi
içerisinde ele alınması, mülkiyet hakları,
insan hakları gibi konular ön plana geldi.
Eğer bunlar olmazsa başka
hiçbir şey olmaz oldu.
Yani olmazsa olmazlarımız
bizim bu kurumsal altyapımız.
Ondan sonra diğerleri rahatlıkla geldi.
Ayrımcılıkla mücadele için
önerilerimiz oldu.
Kadın erkek eşitliğini tahsis edici
bazı önerilerimiz vardı.
Mesela kadınlar ve erkeklere eşit
doğum izni sağladığınızda
kadınların daha fazla iş gücüne
katıldığını görüyoruz.
Eğer biz biraz önce gösterdiğim %30’luk
rakamı %60’lar seviyesine getirirsek
bu Türkiye’ye 250 milyar dolar
civarında bir katkı sağlıyor.
Kullanılmayı bekleyen inanılmaz
bir potansiyelimiz var
fakat bir türlü biz bunu kullanmamışız.
Sosyal alanlarda eğitime ve
sağlığa yöneldik.
Mesela eğitimde şunu gördük, okul öncesi
eğitimin zorunlu olması gerektiği.
Çünkü orada eğittiğiniz çocuk ileride
çok daha başarılı oluyor.
Oraya vereceğiniz 1 lira, ileride size
çok daha büyük bir getiriyle geri dönüyor.
İkinci bir eğitim önerisi ise
müfredatımızın gelişen
teknolojik koşullara adapte
olması ile ilgiliydi.
Bu da mesela finansal okur yazarlık,
liderlik, teknolojiyi anlamak,
onunla haşır neşir olabilmek gibi
bu tarz derslerin de
müfredat içerisine girmesini istedik.
Sağlık alanında antibiyotik kullanımının
%50 oranında azaltılması,
nikotin kullanımının %15
aralığında azaltılması ve
bunun nasıl yapılacağını anlattık.
Şehirlerimizin akıllı şehirler ve aynı
zamanda güzel olmasını istedik.
Şehir bütçelerinin %1’inin
şehirlerin güzelleştirilmesinde
kullanılacak sanat eserlerine
harcanmasını,
ekonomi alanındaki önerilerimiz
Türkiye Cumhuriyeti ekonomisinin
çeşitlendirilmesine yönelik oldu.
Dış politikada kadınları
daha fazla kullanalım.
Türkiye’nin bütün dünyaya yayılmış
insanlarını yumuşak bir güç olarak
kullanmak gibi önerilerimiz de var.
Bunun için kaynakları da açıkçası
nerelerde bulabiliriz diye de uğraştık ve
aslında mevcut bu insan kaynağımızı
doğru şekilde kullanabildiğimizde bu
önerilerle gerçekten dünyanın en iyi ilk
on ülkesi arasına girebileceğimize inandık
Şimdi sizden iki şey isteyeceğim.
Birincisi bizi takip edin.
Size bir Twitter, bir Facebook, bir
web sitesi, bir Linkedin kadar yakınız.
Twitter adresimiz @92Öneri,
web sitesi 92oneri.org
İkinci istediğim şey,
bu bir kahve ile başladı.
Birazdan bir kahve toplantısı
olacak saat 14:45’te.
92 Öneri için çalışan arkadaşlarımızın
birçoğu dünyanın çeşitli yerlerinden
bugün buraya geldiler ve
sizlerin arasındalar.
Sizleri dışarıda bekleyeceğiz. Tanışmak
istiyoruz, kendimizi anlatmak istiyoruz.
Sorularınız varsa sizden
geri bildirim almak istiyoruz.
Ama 93. öneriniz varsa da
bunu sizden bekliyoruz.
Teşekkürler.
(Alkış)